la parole est à monsieur patrice
verchère merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
ce que ceux qui ne rehausse pas le débat
public ce sont les propos du président
public mais pas les questions légitimes
de l'opposition ma question s'adresse à
vous monsieur le premier ministre
alors que le monde agricole vie décrit
sans précédent la réécriture de l'arrêté
du 12 septembre 2006 encadrant
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires fait vivement réagir nos
agriculteurs nos viticulteurs dans un
contexte économique déjà très difficile
un projet d'arrêté interministériel
envisagerait de durcir drastiquement les
règles d'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires
en l'état actuel ce projet d'arrêté ne
peut que légitimement inquiéter le monde
agricole et viticole
en effet ce texte imposera des
contraintes supplémentaires à nos
exploitants par l'extension des zones de
non traitement ainsi des millions
d'hectares de terres cultivables serait
amputé réduit significativement notre
production agricole et viticole jusqu'à
voir la disparition de l'agriculture
dans les agglomérations une stèle de la
métropole de lyon ainsi que la quasi
disparition dans les secteurs
périurbains comme le département du
rhône pleinement conscient des enjeux de
santé publique et environnementaux nos
agriculteurs nos viticulteurs notamment
dans le beaujolais font depuis longtemps
un usage raisonné et raisonnable de ses
produits notamment avec la mise en
oeuvre du plan ecophyto deux mesures le
premier ministre nos agriculteurs et nos
viticulteurs ne peut faire les frais
d'une idéologie et d'une règlementation
punitive qui les fragiliserait un peu
plus face à la concurrence
internationale
monsieur le premier ministre si je vous
interpelle sur ce sujet c'est que la
réécriture de s'est arrêté sans
provoquer des tensions au sein de votre
gouvernement
monsieur le premier ministre même si je
cite l'un de vos ministres
le patron jusqu'à nouvel ordre c'est le
président de république vous restez
encore pour le moment
le chef du gouvernement à ce titre vous
avez normalement autorités pour mes
prétentions et imposer un arrêté qui
puisse préserver notre agriculture et
notre environnement
finalement la question posée par nos
agriculteurs est extrêmement simple
voulons nous encore produire en france
voulons nous encore produire français
la parole est à mme attias stéphane le
foll mais les agricultures de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt cette
présidence le député j'ai l'impression
que la référence à laquelle la référence
auxquelles vous faites
allusion dans votre question serait
peut-être une expression du porte parole
le gouvernement et le premier ministre
ont arbitré et je l'avais dit à
plusieurs reprises il s'agit pas
simplement d'annoncer des choses qui
n'ont pas de réalité pas de faits et de
faire peur à tous les agriculteurs
kantienne discussion interministérielle
qui a été arbitré entre ministères de la
santé de mission environnement ministère
de l'agriculture par le premier ministre
et qu'elle a été l'arbitrage c'est que
nous allons reconduire cet article de la
même manière que ce qu'il existait
aujourd'hui en ne notifiant ce que vous
n'avez pas fait d'ailleurs que vous
étiez au gouvernement à la commission
européenne
c'est ce que nous allons faire donc
cessé d'annoncer des choses qui
n'existent pas c'est le premier point et
l'arbitrage le premier ministre l'a
rendu deuxième point
mais cet arbitrage nécessite quoi qu'il
en soit que lorsque nous avons voté la
loi d'avenir agricole la protection des
habitations sensibles en particulier
dans les zones viticoles soit appliquée
et les décrets et les arrêtés des
préfets qui sont engagés pour 30 d'entre
eux devront être appliquées on doit à la
fois respecter le travail des
agriculteurs permettent qu'il le fasse
dans de bonnes conditions et en même
temps respecter aussi
et il ya des procès qui sont en cours la
situation des habitants et des
habitations c'est le principe qui nous a
guidés donc sur la question vous posez
arrêté reconduit et en même temps
vigilance absolue sur l'utilisation des
phytosanitaires pour la protection des
habitations
merci la parole est à mal